you say ghost adventure yeah i was i was
on ghost adventures
you were on that yeah what do you mean
were you really yes are you terrified
dude so you had to be where'd you go i
was in this haunted mansion in denver
they have this one in kentucky that's
real scary oh they have a ghost dude
really there you are no
it's not you yeah it is
bro you tripping i was so scared joined
by ufc
fighter brendan job i was so scared oh
yeah 100
look at brendan it says my name yeah
it does can you fail can you feel this
gap
yeah i look so scared we're in a
basement
i just repeat everything they say one of
us
they're gonna say brendon it was so dark
down there
no and there was a girl there was a girl
murdered down there
oh this is scene this episode on
lovecraft country
watch it this is also at two in the
morning yeah [ __ ] that brendan
how long were you there for about hours
dude they left me by myself down there
where i live was so scared you can look
this up um
where i lived in athens texas it was
like
like one of like the top most satanic uh
towns in like america uh-huh and uh they
had this thing
it's called fuller's park what i'm just
thinking of alex terrible story
oh you did
have your girlfriend better than malik
okay
look it up texas like satanic
no i'm not at most atmos is a dope-ass
brand
athens athens i know there's athens
georgia yeah there's like a monkey's
bridge there's thing called fuller's
park
they tore it down because there's like
this guy named reverend fuller
this is people have like satanic rituals
in this park
huh it's been years since i've been
there uh what about it doug
but it was just like uh i mean i went to
that fuller's park one time at night
yeah bro it was so scary oh my gosh i i
like that was like i can't do [ __ ] like
this
i did it once and i was like i don't
need to do it again again i don't know
if ghost adventures is real or fake i'm
not saying it's fake i don't know if
it's real but
when i was there that [ __ ] was so real
yeah
yeah i was so scared and they're like
what was that building called i forget
but they're like the
the ghost stopped responding man so
we're going to go upstairs it might be
better if you're just by yourself
what what and like so we'll just leave
you down here like
oh okay i was trying to be tough in
front of the cameras like that sounds
cool
and i'm like where'd the girl get
murdered like right there she's buried
right there she'll just
sit there so you're in this in this dirt
basement where this
literally a person was murdered and
buried there she was raped and murdered
and killed down there
so then they buried her there so i'm
sitting there by myself i was so scared
what about
like an hour how was you sitting indian
stuff i
dude my brother came with me jay yeah
because i because i told zach i went hey
let me know if you want me to do a show
i'm down i love that stuff and i do love
that stuff
my mom's obsessed with it so really when
they called me i'm like oh i'm down
and i was so scared so and then i called
my brother at one in the morning like
hey
i need you to come with me he's like
[ __ ] you gotta pick him up
is that like is that near where you guys
grew up pretty close yeah
oh that's that's straight downtown
that's why like coors field and stuff
and then uh wait didn't that one thing
happen in denver
uh benay oh yeah that wasn't that's
where i lived
oh you oh no you're talking about
jonbenet ramsey yeah that happened in
boulder where i went to college oh god i
got it got it
would you do that show again oh yeah you
would yeah i love zach
would you love to do it now i'm from
louisiana we they believe in voodoo and
stuff like that
i went to the voodoo list yeah i'll do
it oh [ __ ] i would not
i would like i was so much fun too i was
scared was so fun
i'll pass i like i like that haunted
like scary stuff
yeah zach's on like i don't know season
30 or some [ __ ] oh really
he kills it dude oh he's a great guy
fight pass
yo what's it what's on facebook puts
this oh he watches fights i teamed up
to bring you the throw of freaky fights
oh that's cool oh so you're seeing
fights and ghosts
no i think just like you know for like
halloween probably yeah
wait how many seasons is he on i don't
know but he crushes it dude
dude that's you know yeah i'll pass on
that come to death bro
all of a sudden he listens to this and
asks us all to come on he's a great dude
yeah it's so much 23 seasons dude 23
seasons
jesus did you do it would you guys ghost
adventure season you're doing that you
guys were here
you like that scared that you do it with
me oh i do it with you hell yeah
what about you chin yeah of course i
think if the whole squad will do it
he's doing the joe exotic zoo
23 all the ghosts of the ties tigers is
coming up
i'll find out about carol with carol
baskin i'll tell you what's weird is
like i did
i did um i did ghost adventures i did
myth
busters i do ridiculousness right i do
i'm shooting ridiculousness tomorrow
three times
two episodes copied out that stuff's old
then people
will see it for the first time so i'll
get like dms or emails
from ghost adventures from [ __ ] 10
years ago like dude was it
scary i'm like what that was 10 years
ago man yeah but they air it you know i
don't know when they [ __ ] yeah they
just hear it
well that stuff like those kind of shows
are just constantly like hey you look
way different now so i'm trying to
figure out
come on no he's not skin-headed season
19. i've had some work done on my face
yeah you have no i wish i was about to
say i was like would you ever get work
done
never oh love your face just gotta let
yeah
love your face yeah love your face you
look good what else you got jen
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son